well now for the real reason that you're
here Husson Mahna MIT min ha there we go
not related to Nicki Minaj he obviously
made a name for yourself by offering his
comedic take on wide range of stories
for Patriot Act his work has earned him
two Peabody Awards in a spot on times
100 most influential people of 2019 he
often takes on some heavy topics like
drug pricing censorship in China and
student loans Sunday he will take on
another difficult one with my signature
sense of humor take a liver and heroin
because of fentanyl overdose deaths have
exploded now when I first saw this graph
I couldn't believe what I was looking at
it looks like the income of everyone in
Destiny's Child
Hadj good morning you make a lot of
difficult topics easy to laugh at
especially with a week like this one
where we've talked a lot about race
we've talked about politics yeah in your
stand-up the Netflix stand of that I
took a look at you you said that trust
is more important than truth these days
you also talk about being from a family
that came from another country and just
what you had to deal with when you look
at how we're talking about race in
America how important is it for you to
be the person to help people find some
light at the end of the tunnel yeah I
mean well comedy is a really great art
form in the sense that it's about
building pressure through a premise and
then releasing it through a punchline
and if there's ever been a tense or time
for our country its I think you know now
is that time and so it is a really great
time for comedy and our ability to be
able to shed light on these issues I
think you know people come for the
information on our show but they stay
because of the jokes is it tricky to
know when it's when it's too soon to
tell the joke
I think it's it's really honestly a math
equation you know there's just certain
people that can pull it off it's almost
like you know Evel Knievel can you can
you pull off yeah the stunts so
it is a challenge but you know we have
great writers we have great researchers
and it's a case by case scenario how
much of a balance is there between
because you talk about people coming for
the information but it's also the comedy
yes how do you strike that right balance
yeah I mean there's a lot of trial and
error when we're in rehearsal and no it
really is just sort of a gut check thing
in rehearsal well we'll put it up and
you'll just feel it you'll be like nah
too soon or just like for example we're
doing this weekend with the fetanyl I
mean just that Beyonce joke was just
waiting to be that has a personal
meaning for you this helps yeah you know
I you know phenols the third wave of the
opioid epidemic and you know we talk
about oxy but this is a whole new beast
I you know I know people that have lost
their lives to fentanyl and so it was
one of those things where I really
wanted to talk about it because we can't
defeat this opioid epidemic until we get
a grapple and a hold on phenol you talk
a lot about growing up as a kid of
Muslim Indian immigrants yes and being
brown in America yes with everything
that's happening in this country right
now are you surprised by by recent the
recent discourse you know what what's
really disappointing is when you look at
what happened in Ohio and El Paso and
you see these manifestos mmm to me it's
a reminder even though I'm an American
citizen
yeah you know I'm a child of immigrants
you know it's a reminder of are you
wearing a home jersey or are you
perceived to wear an away jersey yeah
and it's stuff like that you know these
shootings reminded me of that the New
Zealand shooting also reminded me of
that of hey even if you are a citizen
people look at you and they see the away
jersey even though you feel in this
country you're wearing a home Jersey
yeah and I think often times when it
comes to the discourse we are so quick
to ramp up and take action if it's
someone wearing an away jersey executing
these attacks yeah it is far more
difficult to look at ourselves in the
mirror during a home scrimmage and go we
have some stuff to talk about
in our own country yeah what was your
inspiration comedic mm-hmm or just in
general when you think about going into
comedies yes I mean you make a lot of
jokes about
you know you don't see a lot of people
that look like you doing stand-up comedy
and then getting Netflix specials and
you've had such great success of who was
your inspiration I was a huge fan of you
know rock Chappelle fire yeah I mean
they're their ability I'm kind of a nerd
I I love speech in debate in forensics
in high school and so to me it was
putting together an argument and just
making it funny I didn't know it was an
art form and then when I got to college
I was like oh it's just funny speech in
debate I can do this here and doing it
very well and let's give the shout out
to in high school in davis california
davis AR that's where people are
watching you that yeah of course thank
you very much for having me all right
then you've one can watch his show
Patriot Act on Netflix on Sundays be
sure to check it out if you haven't
already